okay so this is my little mini review of
Paranormal Activity 5 and also a bit of
an update if some of you are wondering
why there hasn't been like a sibling
rivalry of her bum review of the new
Hobbit movie or why there's now a bum
review of this movie premiere activity 5
we've all been sick man we've all been
really sick like I was just in today
like helping dude test for the gameshow
and stuff and everybody was just like
like Malcolm is sick Jim is sick Rob say
I like everybody's forgetting sick and
there's a virus going around and like
it's taken 4 friggin ever to get rid of
this I'm so weird mutation we've all
gone the doctor it's like yeah just
everybody's getting it so Jason's sick
tooth but you'll see more adventure time
you log so whatever you got your
Disney's embers and you'll still get
your nice - critics but blah blah blah
you want to know what I think of this
new Paranormal Activity 5 let me say
this the acting in this is very good I
think I really want to make that clear
because I think all the actors who
performed in this are obviously trying
their hardest to work with this material
and make this stuff sound natural and
they don't do a bad job and I really
think they should get kudos for it
because of everything else I'm gonna say
in this review man is it bad it's like
really really bad and it's not even in
that category of it's so good it's so
bad it's good it's just bad it's like
boring bad it's like this isn't even an
hour and a half and I felt like I was in
there for two hours
this I'm the guy that even in the worst
Paranormal Activity movie I'll find
something good like I in I don't like
the first one that much by acknowledge
hey it's was doing it loud with a little
and I like that the subtlety of what's
behind the door and nothing being there
can be really creepy in just the little
movements I love that the second one I
thought was wonderful that's the only
one I felt beginning to end was really
really good and really smart good acting
good writing good tying into the first
film very smart
third one I thought it was pretty stupid
but had some really really good scares
and new ideas like the way the camera
would slowly pan over and pan back and
then he pan back over and something
would be closer that's ingenious that's
so smart um and in the fourth one which
got even kind of stupider they still had
some great stuff I love the thing with
that wasn't the connector whatever that
shined all the dots we put the
nightlight on and you see something
moving in the dots or the the knife
thrown up to the ceiling you never know
what's gonna come down those are
ingenious scares even though you sorta
have to sit through a lot of crap that
you've seen like that are really dated
back to the first one you know that they
never quite fixed except for the second
one the second one was the only solid
one uh and now you have this movie we're
the only different thing in it the only
thing that's kind of unique is its
setting it's set in pretty much the
ghetto I guess or in a dangerous
neighborhood because everywhere you look
they're like you know hey don't go there
man that the criminals are hanging out
there the badasses there or whatever and
stuff and this is the other thing that
really made me laugh I don't know if
it's good or bad it's probably bad but
it was entertaining at least they're
gonna go into this place that they've
been to before I get very repeated but
if they're gonna go into this place
where they know bad people are possessed
people are and so and they're bringing
guns like you know these are like
gangsters of seven they're bringing
their guns into this and everyone starts
laughing and sure enough they use it
they use the guns at the end of this and
they're effective and they're blowing
half of these put these possessed people
away and that's great cause it's just
like thank you finally somebody said
let's try this let's try shooting the
fuckers and it kind of works so that got
a big laugh just because we never seen
that Paranormal Activity movie and we're
kind of waiting to and it's it was funny
whether or not it was met you're not
people are laughing and cheering um but
the rest of the movie like everything I
mean everything was from every single
you saw I mean nothing was new really
nothing it's this family that not even
really connected to the other films it's
this
I think Hispanic family and my wife had
a better connection to everything then
then this movie days she leans over and
she said hey the mother was that the
made from paranormal activity - I
thought I didn't think of that that's a
good connection yeah like maybe because
she was very knowledgeable about this
and what makes it no it's just uh part
of the people they're just being
possessed like just people random people
are being possessed now and you know
it's kind of sort of ties back to the
people that are doing it in the other
films I mean at least with the other
films it followed whether it be a kid or
an assister or a prequel or whatever
something connecting to this family and
this really doesn't this is just a
random family uh that happens to be
possessed by these people and what it's
doing to them and so forth and gives a
shit and these the mistakes these people
make even by scary movie standards are
so cliched I mean this is a murder
happens in you know the apartment like
downstairs and these guys Weatherby just
to check out the crime scene for no good
reason of course bring their camera or
to make out with these women that they
just want to get in their pants and
stuff like that yeah cuz that's a real
hot place to make out in the middle of a
crime scene
or this okay all the other films further
problems do a pretty good job in my
opinion a decent enough job explaining
why they can't always get the police
involved or why they can't get other
people involved or half the time they do
and I like that I like when they bring
other people in or I like for example in
the second one where the father wakes up
and says she tried to warn me I'm gonna
bring her back and brings back the maid
who seemed very knowledgeable about this
to help out with things there's one
scene
I think like near the end of the film
where it's like why don't we go to the
police and this is like fucking murders
are happening and they have video
footage of these murders happening and
they never go the cops fucking never and
it's not like they could get caught for
anything it's like they got the evidence
it's it's and only at the end are they
like should we go to the cops and it's
like well do you think they believe us
constantly I mean the oldest tricks that
were done a million times and the other
movies where the you see the back of the
person how many times you've seen this
at paranormal TV movie John you okay
John John all the time ever goddamn shit
and it's nothing new and nothing was
scary I mean nothing it's I'm the kind
of person that will get sucked into this
stuff I know a lot of people say their
patients are tested with these movies
and the shaky camera so that I
understand I really do if it's not your
thing it's not your thing I'm not gonna
totally defend it all the way through
but I was effective for me like even
though the films are bad it was
effective for me
not one scare ever worked in this movie
at all cuz I have seen every single one
of them in the past four and okay I
don't think I'm giving anything away
with this because they say pretty early
on and then they just follow through
with it at the end if you're really
interested after I say this then go see
it you'll love it whatever but this was
the immediate deal-breaker for me okay
how are you on time travel I am not
fucking kidding
time travel that is a thing in this
movie and I heard it
and I just said okay I I doubted these
movies before where their gun going
sometimes they've come around okay let's
uh let's see because even with number
four which I didn't think was that great
I'm sorry like it still kept me
intrigued Oh what is going on what's
what's this all adding up to and they do
it in this movie and it's another open
what does it mean thing it doesn't
really answer any more questions it just
raises it and I'm pretty convinced they
don't know what they're building up to
and even if they do it's not very
interesting because we have fucking
time-traveling in this it is so awful
it's so awful I looked on Rotten
Tomatoes because I feel like the past
couple of movies haven't gotten good
review the first one got good reviews
the second one did and then three or
four didn't I think this got like 53%
they're too fuckin lenient this is so
bad it's so boring it's so cliched and I
just I looked both my wife and I look
forward to seeing these movies around
Halloween like this is our saw I never
got in to saw even the first one like I
never got into it just didn't do it for
me
and they have one every Halloween I
remember a thing going oh won't it be
nice if I could have like that Halloween
movie to look forward to every Halloween
this Halloween they didn't have it so
they waited til the apps are the worst
time to release this movie the week
after New Year's very bizarre but at the
same time I'll say you know what
stuff happens production problems even
though this pretty low-key movie and at
low effects and I mean you wouldn't
think they would need more time with us
but you know okay I'm not unset I don't
know give up the extra time I want them
to get this right I want them to get
this really perfect know nothing about
this indicates there was any extra time
put into it because it is all the same
bullshit horrible
effects and terrible writing I mean
there's a scene where like the the best
friend has the camera whatever the other
friend of course is possessed and he's
acting weird and he's like get out here
man he's like why would you say that man
I'm your best friend cuz that's how real
people talk right why would you say that
I'm your best friend
I'm just establishing my relationship to
you like everybody does in real life and
just on the flip of a coin
you know because you only did one weird
thing so far and I'm gonna say really
bad people really really bad and I
actually wanted to like this movie on a
so bad it's good level because there are
films where I can um you know devil work
that way the room of course work that
way what the hell is the other one
that's a Princess Diaries to work that
way okay I got more joy out of Princess
Diaries - that's how bad this movie is
because it's so repetitive so boring and
nothing new I mean just nothing the fact
that they put it in a different location
was nice you know cuz they're mixing it
up a touch but they do nothing with it
nothing interesting and the fact that
they have some guns at the end that was
kind of nice but even that's not very
long there's a scene where they go into
this guy who says that here's what you
gotta do to get your possessed person to
stop being possessed and they go into
this room there's all these Day of the
Dead sort of statues and paintings and
stuff and you know all the skulls any
you know a David it looks like and I'll
say like what they gonna do with this
like the lights gonna go out you guys
see them shining and stuff like that
nothing fucking nothing and even human
they're gonna get him unpossessed or
whatever like they just ask him to come
in and they just start doing it and he's
just sitting there like they don't even
have to go
him or he doesn't act we're like what is
this or anything okay
there's a fucking Simon game you know
Simon the the four colors and you have
to match them up and stuff that is how
they communicate with the evil spirits
this is fucking real
this is pair of fucking normal activity
five doing this this is the the film
series has brought so many ingenious
scares like even when the stories
weren't good they brought so many good
clever scares to us and now we have them
communicating with the spirits with
fucking Simon is Simon even still made
is that even still a thing like in the
third one they have stuff with 80s toys
like this or I had the Teddy Ruxpin and
stuff and they're kind of making fun of
that like Oh wasn't Teddy Ruxpin kind of
creepy and look at the light bright
thing sir it has the evil symbol I did
the girls do that or didn't do about it
so it's just a little thing in the
background like isn't that kind of cube
but we're not gonna be stupid enough to
actually go all the way with this cuz
that'd be fucking ridiculous this goes
fucking ridiculous
it is so goddamn stupid so think about
who with like this okay get sick I'm
trying to think as I usually try to find
the crowd that would like that of course
there will be a crowd who'll like this
um but I don't know who maybe people who
haven't seen the other paranormal
activities might get a little bit of a
scare cuz some of this might be new
maybe it likes it the acting is good
they gotta work with absolute horrible
writing but I think they pull it off
okay and I think these actors to deserve
a lot of credit this is not easy stuff
to make sound natural but they do a good
job but no it's it's bad it's really bad
um that's about all I got I I really
wish I could think of the crowd or the
people that would enjoy this and but I
don't know I know that at the end I mean
there were a few people sort of doing
the fun little jumps like ah in the
audience but I think again even the
worst movie there was at least 5 moments
where people where the audience jumped
on to it even if it was the fake-out
which there's a couple of those two it's
I could even predict one they were gonna
happen like well it's the first 20
minutes you have someone walking really
close towards a door we know nothing's
gonna happen yet you know it's just
gonna be the guy that goes kaput I
gotcha I gotcha
man you did that 20 other times and the
other film do you really think the 21st
is gonna get us nobody jumped at it um
and I think only at the end I can count
maybe twice in a one and a half I'll say
that people actually jumped and screamed
and the last one was the big I mean the
only time where it really got people
screaming didn't get me screaming but it
really got people screaming was the very
last one where people were supposed to
jump and that was it and people were
laughing at having fun when they got the
guns out shooting you know the evil
people but oh really bad really bad I'm
sorry if you like this movie more power
to you but god I'm curious why if you
liked it to explain why I'm just very
very curious about that that's ain't
talking that way if you really do like
it I mean go ahead enjoy it I am very
curious about what you enjoyed about
because for me it was so removed from
anything that was good with the other
movies so it is something we're into
like I would like to know what what was
actually what you enjoyed about it but
me my I could not get into it it was
definitely definitely not my thing and I
enjoy even the worst Paranormal Activity
movies because they offered something
new and something clever
and I just felt this was all recycled
and phenomenally lazy so yeah that's all
I got for there if you want to look for
like the bum reviews or sibling
rivalries of like whatever The Hobbit or
something like that well we'll probably
have on the DVD because it's a little
late to do now and I couldn't do the
bone review because my voice is already
going and I had to do the emcee today
after I did the NLCS like that so um
yeah that's about all I got man if you
like it great
it didn't grab me man so uh that's about
it now talk to you later
take care